hi welcome to another episode of get
close i'm your co-host gio i'm bart
and i
love these episodes when it just gets to
be you and i because i'm nervous
why
because you told me what you wanted to
talk about for this podcast and then it
made me nervous really
all right well we're going to talk about
some really intimate stuff today um but
we don't have a guest we have mr bear
back
and i actually like
uh the no guest days because you and i
get to bond on a different level just
because we get so busy during the day
and then once work is over we get busy
with the young tykes and then we're
exhausted by the end of the night um
that we literally don't do anything but
like
knock out it looks like it feels like
we're going on a date
right now but then i tried to match you
but then it's like a date
but who knows what the conversation is
going to be and it's inside the house
yeah yeah but this ha this doesn't feel
like we're inside the house because we
did such a good job creating a studio
vibe that it feels like i'm removed
until i hear taika downstairs laughing
yeah that's true um
but speaking of how we just tend to go
to sleep at night
that also means we're not having as much
sex as we could be having um which
brings me to the topic
i wish you could see your faces i should
put a mirror next to my face you can see
the [ __ ] reactions you're giving me
um which gave me the cool idea of
discussing being comfortable
with your partner having sex and yet it
sounds weird right because you're with
your partner which is someone that you
should already be very comfortable with
but i felt like um maybe it's because
you you and i have very low like uh sex
partner numbers yeah that um
uh that maybe we're both not comfortable
having sex and we feel like shy
sometimes do you feel that for me ever
in the beginning i think
i um
i was very uncomfortable having sex with
you
what
yeah you've never told me that i told
you this before not uncomfortable though
uncomfortable is different than either
being shy about it or in your own head
but uncomfortable it's the same shy and
uncomfortable because i took it
negatively yeah you always do
it's just different ways of being
uncomfortable right let me get
comfortable so we're talking about 13
years ago yeah because um
i think like
at least from my perspective
when i love you so much
like um and maybe it could be like just
growing up in the porn generation right
yeah where
like starting when i was 15 or 16 even
on 15 and on 56k when you see pornos
it's like
pound pound right and you're like oh
that's how you have sex
or
um even when you when you're like
jacking off you're just trying to get
one out quick you know you're not trying
to like seduce yourself and like that's
where you're going that's where you went
about it wrong like let me let me uh let
me let me have like four hour sex
sessions right you're just trying to
like bust one out real quick cause your
dad might bust in or something so you're
so even to yourself
yourself here
i gotta gotta get this thing out you
know what are you saying uh what age is
that though because i feel like once you
start 15 16. yeah but then when you live
on your own doesn't that evolve and
change
um i've never had a chance to have sex
by myself for like four hours have you
oh no but i know if like my parents were
out of i never really lived alone until
um years later but like i knew if my
parents were going to be out then yeah
i'm chilling i'm turning on a candle
maybe some music like i'm going slower i
know i don't have to go bow bow bow bow
and like [ __ ] get it out real quick
maybe it's different when you're a bio
major
where time is of the essence and you
never have time the way like business
majors do oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
why
dick what you calling me dumb no like
when you're pre-med right
it's you don't have enough time to study
i see
you wake up you study you go to all the
classes you study on the weekends you
study you work you're studying at work i
used to xerox copy my bio book to go
into the field in the military so i can
highlight and study
in the middle of the [ __ ] mountains
you know
so like we never have enough time so the
minute that i even feel the urge to want
to jack off and even if i want to take
my time
it's i just feel guilty already
oh yeah because you're like [ __ ] i'm
wasting my time i'm not gonna i'm gonna
fill all my classes i'm not gonna get
the job i want yeah am i gonna bust my
way into medical school yeah
okay so that i had so many goals too
like i want to train i want to do all
kinds of stuff i don't know like the
homies are still hitting me oh we go out
so there's just so many things on my
phone i don't have time to do anything
yeah so you just want to uh bang it out
and so
i think um having that
as like
like sex
and then there's also like love making
and there's just a whole spectrum of
intercourse right i think when it came
to you because i loved you so much
um
it felt
like
it felt weird or wrong to turn on like
the animal side of things
you know it just felt like oh god she's
so just such an angel you know got it
like she's so innocent whatever you felt
like then i think that because of that i
project that on myself too
and so i just feel like
like timid too you know so then um
then that leads me to believe that when
you were watching porn and they were
doing this animalistic [ __ ] as as
i'm assuming you saw it as
um
you were seeing it as kind of degrading
or like some [ __ ] you just like that's
just porn [ __ ] that's not wife [ __ ]
yeah yeah i didn't see that i mean like
i mean maybe you blame it on the writers
of the pornos but the directing has
definitely evolved since the [ __ ]
2000s yeah but it's not like after like
the guy busts on her face and then they
get married you know yeah it doesn't
usually go that route yeah unless have
you seen pornos that where they go that
route and then you you you go behind the
scenes and you're like oh these two
actually did start dating like in a
movie well actually porn is so different
now is it yeah it's very different so
now you have like all the different
styles of porn so you have like the ones
that are that are made specific for
women which even it has like a soft
filter on it and it's slower and it's
more intimate it's quite boring in my
personal opinion and then you have more
of the rough sex where the chick is tied
down and the guy's deep throating her
right and it looks [ __ ] crazy i don't
like any of that me neither but this is
the big butt um it looks like they're
actually in a real relationship because
he'll like check in on her like as he's
[ __ ] jamming his like 10 inch dick in
the back of her throat they'll stop and
then he'll like give her like caresses
and kisses and then they move on to the
next wild [ __ ] that's pretty sweet right
so like um i don't blame you for feeling
that way for thinking like okay this
category of sex is animalistic it's raw
it's pornographic and that's some [ __ ]
you do with like hookers or people you
don't care about yeah or your hand or
your hand yeah you [ __ ] that hand up and
then the other category is more intimate
talking and i feel like a lot of that
which is what you call the love making
part right
which i feel a lot of that was um
was kind of fabricated like we were led
to believe that it should be different
but every time i i for me personally any
time i did have sex um maybe because i
didn't consume as much porn as you did
and i didn't um
i don't know i just maybe it's just that
i just didn't consume as much as you did
that like i never really saw it as
different things
how often did you watch porn when you're
like a kid like that
what do you consider a kid like
15 anything under 18. [ __ ] almost never
okay because because remember like when
we grew up the internet was just
starting yeah like we had [ __ ] ass
jeeves when you asked jeeves like what's
the best porno
um i didn't even look i wasn't even in i
didn't even realize that
the internet provided porn like that
when i was first online or for most of
the dudes that i know that was online
the
three the trifecta of internet
is downloading music
talking to friends on aim and then porno
oh [ __ ] it was just that
those three um okay but you were like
okay high school yeah 15 to 20. so i'm
talking about
late 90s early 2000s
the only time i caught glimpses
a glimpse of porn was because we had the
[ __ ] big-ass satellite dish yeah we
would illegally yeah the black box yeah
we would have the black box and then
sometimes you'd get on that channel
where it was like all scattered and [ __ ]
but there were so many people in my
house that like that almost never
happened so i was always in my own head
when it came to like sex or whatever or
just like any scenes that i would watch
and that's kind of i started putting my
own
pieces together and like
girls at least then we weren't really
discussing porno and jacking off and
masturbating like i didn't start talking
about that until i started getting more
on jk news and started uh or not jk news
but just the the youtube space and i
started
getting exposed to different chicks that
were just so open about stuff that i'm
like oh [ __ ] that's that yeah i do that
too you know yeah um so maybe that's
what kind of helped me the fact that
like i just felt like once you're with a
partner
um
there is no such thing as like
lovemaking and [ __ ] there is just
like you can explore the whole thing
with them
um
i understand where you come from with
that
but for me
and i'm not blaming it on porno
because
i'm the one choosing to watch the porno
but it's a combination of things like i
also grew up not just asian which is
already unexpressive
but i grew up um in a way expressive in
terms of you don't talk about emotions
okay emotions like this
right almost as if like
like if someone came and smashed into my
car and i go what the [ __ ]
i'd probably get more in trouble for
losing control than
my car getting smashed
do you know what i mean it's like oh
you're telling me you
you lost your [ __ ] cuz of that like
that's how much you're not supposed to
get too rolled up yeah that's about
anything that's how much of an animal
you are you can't control your impulses
your emotions you know does that come
from
i think like when you date when you not
when you date it but when he like traces
it back to the ultimate like
confucianist idealist
like structure family and all that stuff
which is pretty much like the core
culture of all asian uh cultures
you're supposed to like
hold yourself
to this very like steady
stoic
being
because if you're rocky then you're
gonna affect the other people around you
to be rocky
and so because uh the way that
confucianism is broken down is it starts
with the individual that person be
perfect that person is perfect your
household's perfect your household is
perfect your street's perfect
if your street's perfect then
then can the city be perfect then can
the country be perfect so it starts with
the individual so that's about us so how
they go about it is
all of us
individually control yourselves
when we're when we bring down kind of
like that
that energy level or that angst level
back down you know when you have like
forest fires or oh no it's really dry
it's red all you need to do is like
throw a match and that force is gonna be
a flame right but when you go to like a
lush forest like in seattle or something
it's probably always in the blue and
green it's nice and wet you can throw
all the matches yeah throw all the
matches nothing's gonna happen right so
the way they view it is in terms of your
stability
bring that down a couple notches
then now the government can actually do
its job and go this is what we're gonna
do and everyone jump on board or
if outside factors comes in not
everyone's like
outraged so they've been doing this for
centuries right for maybe
maybe even thousands of years not not
just centuries so this is so
ingrained centuries
centuries not even millennials
falcon i don't even know but it's that's
how ingrained it is in our culture
passed down passed down passing past
down okay
and
with someone like my mom who likes to
take things back to the old school
she was the most asian [ __ ]
that i have ever met like chinese people
have already given up bowing i've only
seen japanese and korean people yeah
stick with that my mom's still having me
balance stuff and i'm like well this is
crazy yeah your mom's like the cousin of
confusion yeah so confucius so with that
um
with that like always control yourself
whatever i never even felt like i could
be comfortable with my parents growing
up in what in what regard the same
regard you're talking about where you're
like
yeah where you're like you know what
like when you're with your partner can't
you feel like you could just let loose
and be who you are sexually you could be
[ __ ] you can be lovemaking you know
what i mean and then i'm like i wish i
could because even at home i couldn't
even be
like you know when you're when you have
a parent sometimes you're your best
friend sometimes you're your teacher
another guardian right sometimes they
are your parent whatever i couldn't be
comfortable being all those things
what's uh what's up what's an example of
not being comfortable because obviously
a lot of people myself included will
understand about sex
like yeah that's just something that a
lot of
cultures deem as like taboos so we don't
talk about that but what about all the
other [ __ ] that you can't be comfortable
with so like uh from what i understand
with all my american friends right
if they need a place to get away in
their house they go to the room yeah in
the room that's their place close the
door
play whatever band they want posters all
over the place you know they can go and
do their thing yep
i pretty much didn't have a room until i
was 13 right because we had four
bedrooms
and there my parents were divorced so to
make the mortgage and to make more money
me and my mom lived in a room slept in
the same bed until i was 13 and then
rented out the other three rooms 13 is
fair i feel like that's when you start
needing your privacy because that's when
you start growing the pubes and getting
the emotions and the body and all that
stuff happens yeah so that's fair yeah
so when i finally got my room when i was
14 i was so happy nice but it's my room
my mom's style
so all walls stay white
i'm gonna inspect your room every single
week i'm gonna pull open all the drawers
and the markers better lay the way
markers should be laying books better be
stacked the way that book should be
stacked
so it needs to look like ikea you know
oh she's checking it every week for that
[ __ ] every week to make sure not to like
inspect like i don't trust you right but
do things right yeah that's like that's
like a standard there's a way you need
to do things and it better you better do
it right oh [ __ ] you know so please
write a book this shit's so interesting
i know so my mom would do that right so
even when like
my friends oh i'm just going your own
room i don't even feel like myself in my
own room everyone goes like you know
there's a home there's that safe space i
never really had that yeah which is
probably why i like i think um
i became so
good at losing myself in my mind because
that was a place that people couldn't
really infiltrate so it's so easy for me
to just daydream and like
be comfortable in here because i think
on the outside in the physical world i
just never felt comfortable
maybe until
um
i think sometimes i'm still dealing with
it now
um
but even like even when we plan for
houses and stuff you know i never really
fight for anything
you know i might go like oh can i have
like just one corner or something
whereas a lot of couples will go no i
need to have this like that pool table
that's me for me it's like i can love
something or like i don't really want
that i'm not trying to get out of here
i'm so used to never owning anything oh
that sucks yeah it's almost like being
in jail right where it's like you don't
have any possessions yeah you're in this
cell for this week no but even they have
[ __ ] posters
true they have posters and all that and
i just
at least from the movies i've never
personally been to jail but from what
i've seen it looks like they have at
least a poster yeah
oh [ __ ] okay so um
you already don't have the expression
given to you so it's it's very much
control everything inside uh coupled
with your you've never even been
comfortable in the place you're supposed
to be comfortable with is uh just
in your [ __ ]
place of residence yeah and my parents
were divorced when i was six yeah so i
never really saw like proper affection
yeah or affection between you know
besides my my grandparents i always told
you i feel like they were my north star
i'm like yes i think that's fair yeah i
think that's fair but like you don't see
them [ __ ]
you don't see them right i'm getting to
that part yeah i hope you never see them
[ __ ] yeah but um what up guys this
episode of get close is brought to you
by manscape who's the best in the men's
below the waist grooming manscaped of
course because they offer precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
i've been using manscaped for over five
years now and i would never go back and
manscape just recently launched the
ultimate men's hygiene bundle the
performance package joining over four
million men worldwide who trusted manske
with this exclusive offering for you 20
off holy moly plus free worldwide
shipping that means doesn't matter where
you are on whatever continent they're
going to hook you up just use the get
close code g-e-t
c-l-o-s-e-m-manscape.com
and if my math is correct that's about 8
million balls so do you know how i used
to cut my ball hairs i used to use my
hair clipper yes the same thing i used
on my head and since i used to cut my
hair and my friends here i've tried all
kinds of hair clippers and they suck for
your balls yes i believe i just revealed
i used to cut my friend's hair with the
same thing that i cut my ball hairs with
i'm sorry guys
but i've tried a single zero double zero
triple zero even with the guard and
since those clippers are made for
hair like like smooth surfaces like your
head i would nick my balls all the time
and i'll be screaming in the shower so
thank goodness for a manscape
that has changed my life number one
there's no cord number two it's a
waterproof number three it has a
freaking light on it and what's dope is
the performance package 4.0 my manscape
has arrived and this is even better
inside the package you're going to find
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer the
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold all of your
goodies is that crazy it's a huge
package and the fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting edge ceramic
blade and this is one of the most
important things ever because if you've
ever used anything else even like a
razor or clippers and you cut your balls
oh my god it hurts so much once you get
into the shower i love that it's also
waterproof because that's where i cut my
my pubes because before i would be doing
in the middle of the bathroom and later
on i hope i don't step on it and spread
it all over the bathroom and i hope i'm
able to vacuum up all the little hairs
but with the lawnmower i just do it in
the shower beam but the boom is done and
it even has the light so when you get
underneath there sometimes you're
nicking yourself because you can't even
see what's going on or you leave a
couple stragglers and you're embarrassed
later but you got a light you can see
everything it's super duper convenient i
love my manscape lawnmower and right now
for our listeners only you get 20
percent off and free shipping with the
code get close that's g e t c l o s e
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com just use the
code get
close unlock your confidence and always
use the right tools for the job with
mansgate but like you have homies that
talk about [ __ ] were they also just
inexperienced or is it just because
girls we go into detail like we'll talk
about like yeah and then he started like
unbuttoning my pants and then this was
happening and then you know and then i
felt this like we're very
vocal and expressive and articulate when
it comes to like explaining the story
from a to z you know yeah what we smell
like what we're thinking all that [ __ ]
is it not that obviously i know it's not
the same for guys but like aren't you
trading experiences no it's not the same
for guys because for girls i think you
really want to walk your girlfriends
through
what happened and put them in which is
mostly as [ __ ] yeah we want to know the
whole details i think for dudes you're
trying to earn your high fives
what's uh what's a high five earner so
like um like let's say he lasted 30
seconds dude i was pounding her for like
an hour yeah [ __ ] yeah bro that was
[ __ ] crazy
you know so it's like guys are gonna
tell things
i mean when guys explain a fight right
yeah i just do stepped up to me at a bar
dude i [ __ ] like i ducked under like
conor mcgregor and then i was like oh
[ __ ] and the phone kicked him and then
you you watch the video and it's just
kind of like this half wrestling
scramble and then the security comes
abrupt and breaks it up and goes yeah i
whooped his ass and i'm like i don't
even think you touched him he didn't
touch you either
you guys just kind of stretched each
other's shirts a little bit yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] funny you know that's
just that's how guys like tell stories
okay
fair especially
in that age you know when you're like
between 15 and 25
it nowadays especially with comedy like
the way that we tell stories on jk news
it's almost funnier when we're
this on the stupid end you know
and and i think you're more secure with
yourself the older you get so you like
explaining it um so now it'd probably be
more the way like you guys would explain
it but at least in that
we weren't none of the stories traded
were helpful yeah okay fair um
so then
you had you were having sex though was
no one giving you any pointers or tips
or like saying anything was that not
even a conversation is it like shy time
is it like oh we we have said oh and
then you have it and you're like let's
not talk about that anymore
yeah my first girlfriend
we lost our virginity to each other i
was 15 she was 15 i think
um and we never really talked about it
after we're just doing it we're just
doing it all the time maybe three times
a day oh [ __ ] these are just
in that age you know and that's it and
that's it and we'll just do it do it a
lot
well i guess it was good i guess that's
our or she doesn't even know either
because she's also a virgin and there's
also these archetypes are fitting in
right at the time so like 15
i'm like asian thug right she's like an
asian chola
so it's like my responsibility to
[ __ ] dick her down and it's her
responsibility to give it up so we're
just doing it you know we don't say [ __ ]
because [ __ ] wayne snitches
you know
so if you think about it just even the
archetypes that you're
that that you are you know when you're
when you're like that it's just you
don't you're just a thug you don't say
[ __ ] you know
like you think [ __ ] like like robert
de niro from goodfellas is like with the
homies and you know it's like it's like
yeah i put her to sleep that's it yeah
next question you know oh [ __ ] okay so
that one makes sense so imagine that
period ain't no one's saying [ __ ] you
know oh my god okay got it what about
the girlfriend after that when it when
is that what age is that
next girlfriend after that wait did you
at least have music or something like
was there any type of
romance or anything yeah i don't know i
picture it so like dry
there's music i picture like both of you
guys never even taken off your pants i
you know those [ __ ] belt buckles the
fabric ones that has your initial on it
yeah yeah yeah you know what it sounds
like yeah yeah i just feel you guys
unclamping putting that [ __ ] down she
has her white spaghetti strap [ __ ]
shirt from like you know what i'm
talking about yeah um you just lift up
your big ass shirt and like just
bend her over that's it done
we done no no no no we put your guns up
no now we're we're naked okay we're
naked and then me and my cousin shared a
room when i was at that time to do it
quietly if he was around
what cousin
uh there's another cousin
oh [ __ ] yeah okay he's on my dad's side
and we shared a room at the time because
that was when i got kicked out of school
and um
my cousin was crushing it in the san
gabriel valley and so my dad asked him
hey would you be down to
move in with me
yeah kind of live by an example and
watch
and so we have two rooms
and instead of like i get my room he
gets his room we both have a sleep room
and we both have a study room uh i see
so it's two desks in one room two beds
in one room instead of bed desk bed desk
so that we can literally yeah live
together yeah
um it didn't help at all your cousin
knew what the [ __ ] was going on
honestly i don't know because you're
such a [ __ ] geek at the time so i'm
15 and he's 17. he's asking me questions
you know oh
because he probably knew what the [ __ ]
was that okay like he was a senior and
then or junior and i was like
yeah you know he was a senior and i was
like a sophomore
and he was asking me like questions
about things oh [ __ ] yeah okay so that's
15. what about the next one
the next girl is still thug life
a little bit better but i think that was
more into like the rave face oh [ __ ] so
maybe i was way more expressive
especially like ecstasy and stuff yeah
and so that
but we still didn't really talk about
sex
you're just more expressive during it
you don't talk about it after what's
more expressive to you
during
probably like more noises and stuff you
know you made noises i don't know like
someone you know when you're on x to see
them grabs like oh i know but when
you're on ecstasy you can't even uh
you're more expressive like oh you he
you know
because when you're on ecstasy like it's
hard some guys at least say it's hard to
even have sex oh no not have sex on
ecstasy but that's the exercise oh
got it so if that's like if that's my
yin to my gang then at least i was
probably more expressive at that time
got it because maybe maybe you were so
expressive before sex that like
it made it even better because this was
already shared but there's an emotional
connection there already established
yeah but you guys were still talking
about it
did you feel uh what did you say about
uh uncomfortable did you still feel
uncomfortable having sex
yeah
why i mean just because i think a lot of
the um growing up my mom covering my
eyes during like romance scenes and
movies you just don't really talk about
that
and then just like the super controlling
never seen my parents show love like
anything in the love romance
realm
just felt like
foreign
and uncomfortable even though i feel it
but it feels uncomfortable you know yeah
but you know when you see david and he
hugs you he just feels good right yeah
and then i see him hug everyone and i
really want to do that i love hugging
people
but i just
don't have the confidence or something
just go up to people and hug them yeah
so i kind of like [ __ ] out and i kind
of do like the half hook being with
people yeah but then i but i on the
inside i want to hug people the way
david hugs people yeah so then is the
uncomfortable feeling coming from um
confidence cause like so for example for
me right when i was having sex and i
feel like a lot of women could relate to
this uh is initially you feel
uncomfortable because you just feel like
your body's
like you're just shy about your body
whether that's your boobs aren't big
enough or they're too big or you have a
pooch or you don't or you're too skinny
or you think you're too fat or you're
you know what i mean like oh this angle
you're gonna see my cellulite oh this
angle i'm gonna look saggy or oh like
um that's where a lot of art
discomfort or like not having confidence
comes from
right but like what about for you
because i feel like guys don't really
have or i don't know i'm assuming here
obviously but
it's not something that men usually fall
victims of i think there's definitely
that too
you felt like your body wasn't good no
my body was good oh okay my bad athlete
my bad dude the first time i felt that
was uh my first girlfriend who were both
15
and you know watching like pornos and
stuff like the guy's picking up the
girls and going all over the place
and then uh so i tried to do that in the
shower and like put her on the wall and
have her legs
but then she was my height so we're both
five eight and then you know like it
doesn't happen it doesn't work that way
because and then you get with even
taller chicks yeah which is why we can't
we can never do that right like i need
someone that's like maybe five three
then i can pick them up to this height
and then i could put it in yeah versus
if she's already my height
if i pick her up then it's like over
here you know so like that was like the
first time i was like trying something
and thinking it's going to happen the
way what i saw
and then we just got to like ignore like
it never happened you know
like whoa that was awkward we tried
moving on yeah but i think with most
um
in couples like the longer you're
together you just get more and more
comfortable so i don't have that with
you at all like i could walk around
naked i don't care it never it didn't it
never felt like you had that with me
ever yeah sometimes my dick is looking
like the most strangest thing in the
world i'm like [ __ ] she already
married me but even before we got
married it was it was very comfortable
time oh really okay but okay so then
that's one i can
scratch out and be like okay it's not
that so the uncomfortable then just
comes from being physical
what up guys this episode of get close
is brought to you by honey the easy way
to save when shopping on your iphone or
computer i know we all love to shop
online right because it's the easiest
way to compare prices versus going from
store to store to store to store to
store
but the thing is the way that i used to
do it is i would buy something on a
website or shop for something on a
website and then i'd have to have two
three four five six seven other tabs
open to keep testing codes to see if i'm
getting the best deal thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past it's a free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one
that it finds for your cart so
imagine you're just shopping on whatever
your favorite site is when you check out
this honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupons you
wait a few seconds and then honey
searches for coupons that it can find
for that site and if it finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop so
for me
recently i'm trying to buy some shoes
for taika and my son grows at a rapid
rate so
every shoe that i buy i know it's not
going to last
the size is not going to it's going to
be under
the priority of him wearing something
that's extremely durable because i'm
going to outgrow it so fast i just need
to get the best deal ever boom good
thing i have honey pops up got a 15 code
and since i was buying a ton of shoes
300 bucks times 15 i saved 45 dollars
guys so make sure you use this because
this thing is free and honey doesn't
just work on the desktop it works on
your iphone and you can activate it on
safari on your phone you can save it on
the go so if you already don't have
honey you could be missing out on a
bunch of free easy savings and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show so get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
get close that's join honey.com
get close g-e-t c-l-o-s-e
and get some savings because it like you
were saying earlier like the expressive
part of it you just feel like it's dumb
or you're just so foreign or you're just
like this i'm gonna feel like i'm trying
too hard or what being physical uh like
physical like physical outside of um
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
pinpoint and better understand
where the discomfort comes from
it's the ability to express myself
in all aspects in all aspects you know
and then so sex is just part of it
but it's just it's hard for me to
express myself in general
yeah
okay
so then that second girlfriend what
about the next one
the second am i the one that you've had
the most communication with then oh yeah
for sure okay yeah
so no other ones were like where you
guys would like stop having like at the
end of sex it's that like cool off
period and you're just laying in bed and
you're talking about stuff and like
that never happened the [ __ ]
not gangster tricks don't do that kind
of [ __ ] so you only dated gangster
chicks or in that period yeah most of
them not all of them are gangster chicks
but just in that period
you know it's like like when you watch
goodfellas right
technically ray liotta
wasn't a gangster in the movie he wasn't
made right the only real gangster was
joe pesci yeah and then robert de niro
because he was half ray liotta was more
than just she never got made man he got
i know
yeah
yeah he grew up in it yeah so like um
that's how it is like even hang
arounders
to regular people are thugs even hang
arounders due time yeah you know yeah so
it was like that like yeah my chick
wasn't in a gang
but i wouldn't be surprised if she
pulled a gun on someone before
you know or my like my third or fourth
girlfriend
um she was on house arrest she had a
probation officer
and i would look at her like if we
weren't together
i would look at her as a wannabe even
though she has a probation officer it's
just that's how
gangster the spectrum is how gangster
the gangster is yeah it's like it's like
she has a probation officer she's on
house arrest and other people would
still go
oh she's innocent she never did no crime
she just got a probation officer that's
nothing yeah you know oh [ __ ] yeah okay
and then just for um
just so that
we're on the same page
um
you've had less than or like you can
count all your partners on one hand
honestly i don't even remember me think
i know i had to think about it too
because me yes because we've been
together for so long yeah i know me is
literally just the one hand i'm done so
the last three
were just you
gio
you know let me think
because one time i was talking to a
friend about it and i left one of the
girlfriends out just because that's how
long ago it was you know yeah so yeah
how i had
a girlfriend
mm-hmm
partners or girlfriends whatever i mean
sleeping whoever you've had okay yeah
yeah sex so my first girlfriend or first
one or two girlfriends who never had sex
because i was too young yeah i'm not
talking about that because i've had i've
had boyfriends that i never slept with
okay yeah
i think you're my fifth partner yeah
yeah yeah okay so we're the same five
high five
yeah we're the same so it makes sense
um everything you're saying it makes
sense and i think it's really dope to
like talk about this [ __ ] yeah cause
like um
like i kind of knew this stuff about you
but like when we first had sex like the
very very first first time because um we
did share our our our love story again
after i don't know how many years like
maybe even 10 years
so definitely check out that podcast it
was [ __ ] cute it took me back and
i love you yeah it's called how we got
together yeah cuny um but
yeah so the first time we had sex it was
such an intense connection that like
all you had to do was just hug me and i
was already gonna bust
that sounds weird but like have an
orgasm like you just it was just so
intense but then the more we
got to having more sex it like
became very cold
and it was just very uncomfortable
because it just felt like this person
that i first had sex with was just gone
and then it turned into the pound pound
pound yeah um
that's what i felt like was doing the
right thing you know i felt like i was
that's what i was supposed to be doing
and i was like damn what's that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was doing in the first the
first time around no the first time
around was great i know but i didn't
know and then i think we started slowly
uh having less of it because we just got
so busy and then just just our
relationship started taking a different
turn
um but yeah we didn't i don't remember
really talking about it with you i just
thought like
i just felt like i needed to suppress
like
my own
lustful wants because i just felt like i
was too horny or too turned on and i and
and you didn't didn't express any of
that
um i didn't it's just inside i didn't
let it come out yeah like i remember
like um i felt like a hoe like i felt so
slow here's my backstory um
i grew up
seeing affection receiving affection
um my dad was like the [ __ ] coolest
like he gave me too much affection where
i was just like [ __ ] stop smothering me
dad you know he gave me too many hugs
and he would like
uh he would do like the cuny like a
little butt tap you know what i mean to
the point where even now i'm like good
whenever you want to like i walk by and
you want to slap my butt like i know how
to deflect it because like that was just
my dad he just thought i was the cutest
thing ever
and yeah he would just smother me all
the time or i could like if he was home
and he saw me come by like he always
wanted like a kiss you know and i was
like oh dad come on
and he's like oh really oh really and he
would like hold me and he'd give me a
bunch of kisses and [ __ ] so i received a
lot of that affection yeah
but i grew up in a household uh that was
very religious right catholic um but
like not religious to the point where my
mom like it took over the whole house
but like enough for you to know that
lustful
like desires and like thoughts and
seeing [ __ ] like that's just some hell
type of behavior like if you want to go
to hell you [ __ ] partake in that [ __ ]
you know yeah um and especially you
don't do that stuff before you're
married it felt like once you get
married you have the [ __ ] green card
or like the the
the
pass whatever card to just [ __ ] go
all out but i wasn't married so like we
didn't talk about like we barely even
talked about what my body was gonna go
through during puberty
like i remember i got that talk and i
was helping my mom make dinner and we
were back to back she's prepping food
i'm prepping food and she goes hey uh so
you know your body's gonna start
changing right and then like this is
just weird because me and my mom don't
have these
types of conversations and i was like
well what do you mean so then she starts
telling me like yeah you know your trust
might start growing like you're gonna
tell you after you had changes already
i think that'd be so like you have
you're like bleeding all over your leg
she's like you know a period is going to
come um i think it might have spot i
think that might have happened because
she saw that i had started in my period
oh i see yeah cuz i remember i was on a
i was on a fishing trip with my pops
just him and i
and um
it always sounds like like when i'm
saying these stories i feel like i
always leave my brother and sisters out
but it's just because our age gap is so
big that like when i'm like eight my
sister's what's eight plus 15. oh
twenty-three yeah so she's twenty-three
yeah she's definitely my brother right
my brother is ten years older than me so
he's eighteen he's trying to hang out
with his chicks yeah he's boning chicks
at home you know and then if i'm eight
my little sister's two cause she's six
years younger than me so like a lot of
these stories are gonna feel like i'm an
only child because it was really that so
i'm on this fishing trip with my pops
and um
and i don't know what he was doing but
like i go to the bathroom my i see blood
on my underwear and i'm like oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on so
come back from the trip i put that
clothes to get washed and my mom sees it
so i think that week if not a week later
my mom it's like she has that
conversation with me we're not making
eye contact in the kitchen prepping food
and she starts telling me about like how
my body is gonna change and i'm gonna
get hair in places i'm not used to but
she didn't even specify like i didn't
even know what the [ __ ] that was she
felt awkward on her own yeah like it was
probably like a five minute conversation
and then she says but don't tell anybody
don't share this with your friends
because i don't want parents and
teachers coming at me telling me that
like uh getting mad at me for sharing
this stuff and i'm like okay i'll never
talk about it i never was told i was
gonna get
hair in different places ever maybe
because your mom didn't get here in any
places
you guys you don't even have any hair
have you seen my mom's armpits no i
haven't you've never seen her try to
hang clothes outside no that's [ __ ]
gangster
i bet it's not that bad it's like she's
asian it's on that it's a full imagine
like a fully
black skunk
no white stripes oh [ __ ] no it's crazy
okay yeah um so then yeah that's not my
mom doesn't shave her armpits either
fine and she likes baby powder got it so
it looks crazy up in there
how you love women after that i'm
surprised it's a miracle yeah i'm
surprised
uh so yeah and then every room in our
house had like the angel that like
that like you see two kids crossing a
bridge and there's like this angel
that's like watching over them yeah so
there's always a sign of god in every
corner of the house like in my mom's
room she has the picture of jesus or if
we're not we have like the crucifix
everywhere or the virgin mary like
there's just all over the [ __ ] wall
and and you know we go to mass
i've made my confirmation my first
communion and they talk about like
sinful stuff like like uh you're not
supposed to sin and these are the sins
that you're not supposed to commit um i
remember going to uh the confession room
having my confessions i've even had iv
i've even had confessions with the
priests like this face to face like
that's so
[ __ ] scary there's not that thing in
them i've had that yeah but also there's
some that you just sit like this [ __ ]
that yeah i ain't confessing [ __ ] yeah
yeah i mean you ain't no rhett
but like so that's my upbringing right
like it's constantly drilled in your
brain that like
no premarital sex like forget about
masturbation nobody even talks about
that
um and like
uh we weren't like if there was a
kissing scene like just to even like a
slight you know that it's gonna lead to
them being not even intimate but just
having a first kiss my mom like if we're
watching something she'd be like
oh okay so then like she just start like
getting all skittish and stuff and like
trying to deflect the tension away from
the tv to something else like you you
even now you'll see her panic like watch
her and she'll like start panicking like
trying to change it or walk away yeah
um so that always felt really
uncomfortable for me even now
at [ __ ] 38 years old when there's an
intimate love scene i hear my brain
going let's go away let's start a
conversation let's panic let's like
let's not pay attention to this oh look
away but then i'm fighting it going what
the [ __ ] shut up let's watch it like i'm
forcing myself to be comfortable in that
uncomfortable have you ever asked your
mom are you good in bed
i don't want to know
that that's not some [ __ ] i want to hear
about my mom but the funny thing is to
know that like you know like the way
she's acting in real life yeah like why
you know like if you if you like make
dad bust in like 60 seconds and you just
own it
why are you so shy over here unless
you're also just not expressive and shy
in bed
um i think it was like multi-layered so
i think for my mom
she also wanted to raise like decent
women um that weren't gonna sleep around
they weren't gonna be hoes um they
weren't gonna get pregnant at a young
age
um
and and she wanted us to follow the life
path right go to school get your degree
get a nice job marry the man of your
dreams then move out get a house have
kids
so i think she was creating that
life for us
um but the closer i got to her in the
recent years and now i'm an adult and
you know we're like it seems like we're
now peers and friends yeah yo she tells
me some crazy [ __ ] and i love it but
like i'm just like
oh [ __ ] like ma you can get it you know
like they were just little like dirty
birds like my mom
tell me something i don't know like my
so growing up too like i would see my
dad always make advances at my mom but
because i'm so young i didn't really
realize what was going on like he'll
grab her ass but like
not grab her ass like a cheek like he
gets the middle part because he wants
like both cheeks and some of the front
you know what i mean like he gets in
there he got good grabs under the skirt
like [ __ ] like that and like i and i
remember like they would say make like
sexual innuendo type comments
finger too i don't know not like that
that's awesome but like um i just
remember now looking back at it going oh
[ __ ] they were flirting like all the
[ __ ] time yeah yeah so they were
[ __ ] getting it you know what i mean
no you didn't tell me anything does your
mom like try to look for flashlights in
her dad's pockets
i don't know like she didn't tell me
[ __ ] like that she would say more so
what my dad would do you know what i
mean she would giggle about it yeah of
course like she loved that [ __ ] you know
so um
so i think that upbeat upbringing was
for
us to be decent women in their eyes
um so because of that i was also
you know when i was having sex like
um i was i i had seen porn stuff and i
thought that that's what women were
supposed to do like be loud and scream
and like uh uh and be like extra hot and
the makeup's supposed to look really
good obviously i didn't see the [ __ ]
deep throat ones where like mascara is
running and [ __ ] snot and they're
vomiting i'm not a fan of any of that
stuff fine but i'm just saying i didn't
see that stuff so i didn't even know
that was that around i just
like our our era of sex was like the
fake boobs and the perfect
hair and makeup and all that right
um that i when i first started having
sex i thought that's what it was i
thought that's what girls needed to do
they just needed to look perfect all the
time um
but after a while i i kind of like
got
kind of comfortable pretty quickly so i
didn't really get i didn't need to like
i didn't feel like i was separating
anything like i just felt like
you get to do everything with your
partner like you sometimes you want to
[ __ ] sometimes you want to go slow
sometimes you want to go
i don't know weird
you know yeah and you kind of just
explore it with with your significant
other and it's like a safe space if you
will i see yeah
so when it was like
um
so when it was time to have sex with you
like it started off that way and it was
comfortable and there was this
connection which i had never experienced
actually
um i just didn't know that
that existed i didn't know that there
was like this like energy like this like
i can't even explain it like um
yeah it just felt like this energy of
like like massive connection like it
felt like you were like
like our hearts were like [ __ ]
intertwined and like beating out as one
it sounds [ __ ] funny why are you all
like yeah like it just felt so intense
too
hearts too hard that be as yeah
so it felt like that so i was just like
mind blown yeah like it didn't matter
what the technique was it didn't matter
what any one of us was wearing or doing
or where we were it was just like
i was like
transformed or like transported into
this like
outer space outer body type of thing
and i was like holy [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] crazy
yeah so it didn't matter like what what
noises i made or whatever the [ __ ] it
was just like this crazy connection this
melting of like souls and [ __ ] yeah
um
but then the more we had sex like
that like
went away really fast
and i didn't even i didn't know why me
neither i think maybe the first time we
had sex
we didn't know we're gonna have sex yeah
so i think we were just trying to hug
but the clothes kept coming off oh come
on who [ __ ] who no you didn't know we
weren't having sex because that's just
stupid
no i don't think we shut them i always
know no i'm planning always know okay
any time i think we're just trying to
hug and then you know i always know when
sex is going down now we were trying to
hug but we just didn't want all these
clothes no
[ __ ] no anytime the lights are dim
there's some [ __ ] going on anytime
you go
anytime
we're [ __ ] we need to turn the lights
on fine sure but i'm just saying if the
space is comfortable dude you were in my
room door closed lights off on top of my
bed you thought we were gonna [ __ ]
hug all night are you dumb i thought
we're gonna hug all night you swear to
god
i don't know what's gonna happen no it
sounds like you're joking right now i
really don't know what's gonna happen
are you kidding me i mean i thought like
so let me explain myself please cause
i'm just [ __ ] blown away i'm not i'm
not that uh what's the word calculated
no i don't want to jump to conclusions
the way you do no i don't either but
everyone can it's a [ __ ] movie trope
dude yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
that's and tropes are jumping to
conclusions right because it tends to
happen that way so you see a guy like
walking behind an alley off fast with
his hand in his pocket you think has a
gun for sure but i'm not judgmental
i'm like he might be offering me flowers
or his hands might be that's just dumb
there's a million other things right i
like to keep my options open so when
we're in your bed i'm like probably we
probably are gonna have sex
but i loved you so much at that time
i just enjoyed hugging you i wasn't even
thinking about [ __ ] um
obviously i was horny but i wasn't
trying to entertain that part of it you
know
no i don't
because for me in a relationship
um
if i'm in a relationship that's it i'm
giving you my all if i'm not in a
relationship yeah if we were just
talking and then you come into my room
i'm not going to assume sex is going
down because i i don't want to have it
with you
you know i'm not going to have sex with
someone unless i'm like with them right
that was my mindset yeah so then like um
if i'm with you i'm giving you my all
yeah like that's it like whatever you
want to take it's all yours so if we're
together
we're [ __ ] dude
thank you
that's [ __ ] interesting
this is the type of conversations i feel
like every couple should always have
like before you get with someone i think
it's important to talk about sex i think
it's important to talk about everything
to be honest yeah talk about sex talk
about um how they see their family
structure talk about how many kids i
think it's so important yeah and also
even like definition of financial
success yeah uh
the definition of familial success too
you know like is your definition of
because you might have to support people
yeah is your definition of familial
success like
crush it and work so hard but then
you're never home yeah you know or even
extended family yeah or is your
definition familiar success is any side
of the family that has an emergency they
can move in at any time yeah because
there's people that have the [ __ ] no to
the in-law rules like i don't care what
happens if your dad is in trouble we'll
give him a retirement home but no one's
moving it but you know just yeah and
these are all fair things all these like
major life details i think are really
important to discuss yeah
um and it felt like we didn't um
get to have this conversation
until we really started repairing our
our um
our relationship i don't even know if
we're mature enough you know a lot of
these topics
it's like you learn about finances
and stuff in retrospect yeah
you know when you're a kid you don't
know [ __ ]
and then you're just like impulsive and
you're just going with the flow you're
just kind of winging it
and
um you don't even know
what to talk about like i didn't even
know
that how i grew up
affects my sex life you know it takes a
lot of introspection
to like
um
figure that out
and get yourself there right versus now
we've had so many talks that we've been
able to peel back all the layers yeah
and we also grew up in an era where um
there wasn't internet and people weren't
as open as they are now and it's like so
cool you have people like shannon right
who's constantly
discussing and um normalizing a lot of
like sexual desires and like sexual type
of approaches um relationship styles
like she's so open about how her and her
husband have like an open relationship
whereas back in the day open
relationship just meant you were
confused yeah and it meant like you just
didn't want to commit and you had
commitment issues right but like now
we're way more educated and we have a
lot of access to like studies or just
these people um that have like
experienced it and you're like oh [ __ ]
it can actually like it's mature and it
works yeah but yeah you're absolutely
right because like um
i don't know maybe i would have taken
this stuff personally you know like if
you would have said like i feel
uncomfortable having sex with you i
think maybe i would have shut off like
[ __ ] you out and shut off and like now i
don't even want to have sex with you
because i think i'm taking it personally
yeah and everyone has their own
insecurities yeah so who knows how
people take things and project things
you know yeah i've even heard couples
talk about like a girl will bring a sex
toy into the relationship like uh if
they're gonna have sex she'll bring her
sex toy because that's just what she's
used to and she's open about it and then
the guy who's insecure about that might
take it as like oh i'm not good enough
for her i'm not big enough for her or i
don't just competition now yeah yeah
like oh and like oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know and now you deem her the bad guy
when it's like shouldn't even be about
anything bad
um
but yeah it wasn't until we started
repairing our relationship that i like
i was inquisitive
about like what actually turns you on
like i didn't even know like i just
thought every guy got turned on by the
same things so i remember a time when
our sex life was really dry and bad that
like um i would
my version of sparking things uh was
to like wear a long t-shirt with like
nothing underneath and you can kind of
see my ass cheeks and then you wouldn't
even care
like you would like not say anything
about that and i'm just like
okay i'm really wrong
and that would i think i probably
started taking that personally like oh
all right i i feel like a [ __ ] instead
of just talking about it yeah like i
just felt like you were so focused on
work and so focused on building
um that you didn't have time for these
like animalistic desires or distractions
that i started going like why do i have
time for that like what's wrong with me
why do i why do i want it so many times
like why do i want this so bad and i'm
like oh
and then it takes me back to my
upbringing of like [ __ ] bhuta and you
[ __ ] and like why do you have this
desire like you're such an animal you
know and then now trying to suppress
that and be like no no i'm not that i'm
like this righteous queen who like has
zero distractions and like
i don't know has zero emotion i guess
yeah it felt like that
yeah i think like couples
when they first have sex
i think it would actually be really good
the way you engage in a jujitsu role
explain
so like
i think when couples have sex because
you know meanwhile you thought you were
a [ __ ] right
i felt like i was a dirty [ __ ] too
because i'm jacking off in the backyard
not trying to like have you
feel like i'm like the sex fiend
yeah right oh man i would have loved to
watch your jackpot
but i'm like busting nuts all over the
[ __ ] lemon trees
those are some good lemons though yeah
all right
that backyard got [ __ ] fertilized so
nicely yeah dog piss dog poo homie tyson
not meatloaf we'd love to make it there
but like fawn
brown like so many different and like at
least four dudes urine
yeah
yeah that those that tree was got
[ __ ] semen in there yeah there's a
bunch of stuff um
i think like
when you have when you first go into sex
you're coming in with your own
insecurities yeah so i think both sides
probably come in with
i need to perform at my best make an
impression
i need to do some [ __ ] some ab work
too yeah the oppression doesn't
necessarily make the best sex the
connection does right
we learned that a decade later yeah
and i think
that's why it reminds me of jiu jitsu
where when he got two white belts
what they're worried about is winning
yeah who's winning that one move
got to pull it you know yeah you're in
your own head and then so
that's not really a good role you know a
good role is like oh cool i saw what
you're trying to do and this is what i'm
trying to do and there's like
it's good jiu jitsu not a good match
yeah right whereas i think two white
belts are trying to have a good match um
and then but then also i think when two
people go in to engage in a role for the
first time it's like oh what injuries do
you have
i have this stay away from this okay
cool cool okay cool what about you so
kind of talk talking about all that
stuff before having it and i think when
you when you hear it it sounds kind of
logical and it sounds unsexy
but i feel like that's probably like one
of the healthiest way to go about it
yeah i love that yeah cause like you
know we all come back we all come from
like
different experiences some of us have
some trauma and [ __ ] and and some of the
some of us might
uh like to engage in more experimental
type [ __ ] and if someone with crazy
trauma with like super experimental
don't talk about it and they try to get
into it that just sounds like
something's gonna go wrong in the middle
of trying to be intimate with each other
and it might be something where like it
turns each other off so much that like
that's it that relationship can't work
yeah because if someone's like um
let's say has a traumatic thing with
like lights on or lights off oh yeah and
you wait till it happens to to
figure that out
it might ruin it you know but if you can
talk about all that stuff
oh man yeah when i have sex i have to do
then you're both in a calm state oh
really i'll come
you kind of are able to walk through
almost
all of the likes and dislikes of sex
before going into it then it probably
feels extra safe yeah for sure yeah yeah
i'm trying to think back like when in my
20s would i have been as
it's hard right because you don't even
know who the [ __ ] you are in your 20s
you don't even know like you were just
saying right like you didn't even know
that your upbringing had anything to do
with how you're doing and uh engaging in
sex
like we don't really connect the dots
like that um it's not until
um
you're probably in your 30s or late 20s
maybe
that you can start maybe some people
don't even know it now
damn yeah being a human is [ __ ] hard
it's really hard
it's hard because
most of the time you start um
you start with the handicap
yeah with your parents trauma yeah and
then so they put that on you because not
even your parents trauma it's like a
generational trauma yes their
grandparents you know so their parents
and their parents after that so you're
starting with uh
slight insecurities
and then you're thrown into the future
where a generation like imagine like my
parents now trying to navigate right
like in the back of the day where it's
put your head down and work
and now people are like so in touch with
their feelings and mental health and
stuff like that like i don't even know
if i can have a conversation about
mental health my parents yeah they're
not gonna know what the [ __ ] i don't
even know what the hell is like shut the
[ __ ] up stop making excuses and wasting
goddamn time yeah they're like what the
hell are you [ __ ] talking about you
know so it's like but every generation
is kind of like shot put it forward into
something like that you know
so i think like it's it's tough being a
human being is very hard yeah i think i
would if like um i went back into the
dating scene yeah it's not going to be
as sexy but you cut through the [ __ ]
a lot more that's why i think when
people remarry
or or they marry late later on in life
i'm talking about like 40s 50s it feels
like it's so fast
because it's just like they cut through
a lot of the [ __ ] they're like okay
the rest of this is noise and i don't
need it
what's your like you were saying like
what's your financials what are the
financials like for you what does like
success mean to you huh tell me about
your past like all of that stuff whereas
um
i remember one thing that i loved about
getting in a relationship or starting to
date was like the peeling back of the
layers like i love that [ __ ] like i love
like
getting lost with the other person and
trying to like discover all their [ __ ]
now
i don't know i don't think i give a [ __ ]
i think i just want to get straight to
the point i don't want it to be so
[ __ ] organic yeah my dad when he he's
when he dates now he says like his go-to
questions
before they even talk about anything
sexy or whatever
or any flirtatious is are you in debt
are you citizen
um do you have any kids
and do you own your house
damn because it's
if they don't own their house
and my dad wants the person to move in
with my dad as an equal yeah as an equal
and because they want to not as a
default oh my dad's a homeowner and then
also my dad doesn't want to get into
something where my dad spent 30 years
securing his finances and then now he
gives up 30 years trying to fix someone
else's because their finances are jacked
up yeah so it's like the real real you
know yeah cause like
obviously none of those questions are
sexy you want to get swept off your feet
and all that stuff but when it comes
down to it
you're trying to live
real life and those are the most
important things in real life yeah
yeah that's dope it's not sexy at all
but it's very immature so hopefully he
can present that and then he just
[ __ ] dicks him down real good
seems like my dad's good that's what my
that's what joe told me to live with my
dad he said he'd come downstairs and my
dad would be motorboating the chick's
vagina how come he never do that to me i
just did that last night no but like
he's they're not doing it naked
he's doing it because he can't control
his [ __ ] urges oh could you [ __ ]
push me away you hate him yeah no i know
because tag is around but yeah i'm
[ __ ] around um okay
so
damn that's very insightful [ __ ]
like just
upbringing leading back to like emotions
with relationship all that how is it now
for you and what at what point did
things become less uncomfortable are you
still uncomfortable a little bit
a little bit what so uncomfortable yeah
a little bit where does that come from
i don't know i think the trauma is just
so deep you know where it's like um
and i grew up extremely religious like i
i pretty much but we're married we did
everything by the book i know that's the
crazy part where um
i pretty much was like a hair away from
becoming a monk when i was like eight
you know so it's just like
even when we have sex the first initial
thoughts i still feel guilty
and then it's like oh it's just my wife
we have a kid what are you talking about
you know yeah by everyone's book no
matter what [ __ ] you look at yeah
we're killing it yeah but it's still i
still have these weird feelings
sometimes you have to push them away
[ __ ] yeah i just have a lot of like deep
trauma i guess and what else makes you
feel uncomfortable
just that oh just it's just on the
inside you know
that i have to deal with with like my
own weird thoughts yeah what helped you
become less uncomfortable
are you just doing it more
oh so not even talking about it not
learning more about each other just
doing it more
because my thing that i love doing and
i've always done this is getting
feedback at the end of everything
i feel like i hand you a survey
so for me i like if it's good for me i
don't want to assume it's always good
for you so then i always like to discuss
like what was good what could i have
done better what's like i like that open
dialogue because it allows
for us to just be better for each other
that's pretty cool
oh you don't care that didn't help you
i mean i could email you
what the [ __ ]
no
it's it doesn't help me because i think
it's my own [ __ ] oh you know what i mean
it's not it's not just you i could have
sex with someone else someone else
someone else someone else doesn't matter
i still feel that way because it's my
own trauma yeah it's my own thing you
know
so there's nothing really
you can do
to make me feel more comfortable yeah
you know
damn that's a good point yeah it usually
is that way it usually is it's not the
other person it's most of the time it's
your own [ __ ] that you gotta sort out by
yourself for yourself and it's cool to
have a partner that's
open to um holding space if you will for
for you to allow you to do that and not
judge you and not take it personally
um
uh so that you can sort that [ __ ] out
yourself this is how weird i feel you
know we're planning on having a second
kid yeah
like when i present that to my parents
the first feeling i get
should be
i'm so excited we have a second cave to
bring more to the family right but the
first feeling i actually get
is oh my god i feel so guilty for having
sex or having another kid
even though we already have a kid got it
that makes sense which is like what the
[ __ ] like yeah because it you wouldn't
feel guilty so it has nothing to do with
the second kid it's all about the sex
because now you're admitting that you
have sex openly to your parents more
than once yeah
yeah and they know what and you know
that they know that it doesn't it's not
the first time that you have it and then
you have a kid so it's not like you've
had sex two times yeah it's like you've
had sex a lot that means i'm having sex
for fun yeah i get it yeah i'm not
having sex to make kids i'm having sex
with fun yeah i get it um i i felt that
way the first time i announced i was
pregnant because now like you're openly
admitting that you've had sex at least
once um but after that like
yeah no when you hear my brother and his
[ __ ]
he'll talk about a stuffed animal that
they put on the [ __ ] not my brother
but he'll talk about his stories with
his friends openly my mom's that
everyone's there he's talking about oh
is that why you have a stuffed animal
against the headboard so it doesn't make
noise at night when you guys are [ __ ]
and i'm going
and my mom's all cracking up and i'm
like oh this is some [ __ ] i gotta start
out on my own because your mom's no one
else your mom's raunchy she loves that
[ __ ] uh very classy she lets you be
raunchy and she giggles because she's a
lady but i know what that giggle means
though yeah no of course she's she's
letting loose you know but um
yeah this is uh yeah i i i like we said
like i said right like you just got to
sort this [ __ ] out on your own and
hopefully you have a supportive
circle
uh around you that allows you to do that
without judgment because could you
imagine if you're like feeling that way
and now i'm taking it personally so now
you're dealing with your own [ __ ] not
having to comfort me because i feel like
i'm the only one that's lacking here and
it has nothing to do with me yeah that's
tough that [ __ ] suck yeah
yeah i think good resources would be
following people like shannon um and
then follow whoever she follows because
it's
they're like very open-minded very
insightful very educated people i love
it i love the topics that she talks
about because i i'll be like oh [ __ ] i
didn't even think that that was a thing
and i love it
it's really cool
but
sex with you now is [ __ ] awesome
i feel like i feel like every time we
have sex now it just um beats the last
time we've had sex not that like it
needs to beat anything but it just feels
so good and so connected and you feel so
much more confident whereas before you
felt a little bit timid to me you felt
so shy
i still feel shy now
no
now it feels like
like you're [ __ ] owning it and you're
just like this is [ __ ] mine and i'm
like yeah [ __ ] it take it it's yours you
know it feels good like you like i feel
your strength now whereas before i'm
like why why why does [ __ ] have
all these [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
muscles and he wants me he wants to be a
little spoon the [ __ ] this is weird he's
cute
sometimes it's cute cause the obvious is
lame
no that's why i got with you the [ __ ] i
wanted a strong guy it's like [ __ ]
feel a little i'm a big [ __ ] you are
big [ __ ] hey dude
i'm just kidding um but yeah anything
else you want to add
you [ __ ] frog face
i don't know just reminded me of that
but
yeah thanks for always being so open
with me and thank you for always
i always like whenever i ask a question
it can be taken very lightly and it can
be i ca i can be given
a very sh quick straight answer but i
really appreciate you for like
stopping and there's silence and it
feels like you're really like breaking
down my question and trying to
understand where this root of the
question is coming from and it always
feels like you give me um a lot of
respect for one two it feels like you
really
want to also get to the bottom of
whatever it is i'm trying to get to the
bottom of um and it always feels so
honest well they're good questions too
so they're questions i've also never
asked myself
and then so they're like questions and
i'm like wait i should know this
you know yeah i should know this at the
forefront of me
because this is who i am
so it almost feels like um someone going
like yo what's your social security
number and you're like
i [ __ ] should know this [ __ ] oh so
i'm like i look i hurry up and write it
and so i could fill in my bling because
i feel like in my identity or anybody's
identity
you should know what you are yeah right
so that way when you go into the mingle
in the real world
you know how to like properly navigate
and mingle with people
and then so for me i'm like oh [ __ ] i
didn't even
never thought that deeply about myself
oh yeah this is my favorite color so
when i'm gonna go buy things
like this color is part of my identity i
should always buy things like this color
that'll make me happy because i remember
this makes me happy yeah yeah well damn
i guess we're cuny i guess so well i
love you thank you for always sharing
with me i love you too and i love you
guys thank you guys so much for tuning
in i hope we were able to give you some
insight in terms of like uh how to have
deeper connections with your partner or
at least how to start these
conversations and knowing that you're
not alone when it is that you feel like
um you're the problem or there's just
some weird [ __ ] but you're just too shy
to talk about it i always think it's
always so good to talk about it so i
hope we were able to shed some light on
that and um thank you always really
appreciate you love you guys and we'll
see you guys next week bye